[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Applause]
hello and welcome to monthly dose of all
things eSports here on the open eSports
report I'm Rachel stringer and this is
my partner
I'm coming they'll cover this we're
gonna be mark after you made me out in
time and this is I love you make about
this gesture you shouldn't be here right
now I'm sorry that's a hundred my fault
sorry sorry you are you ready just about
okay this is Mark Hatcher as I say and
here's what's coming up on tonight's
show coming up on tonight's show we'll
give you a bite-sized recap of all of
the latest news in the eSports 60 we
head to Cologne Germany to check out
Gamescom we learn about the rise and
fall of quake and we'll be joined in the
studio by some very special guests loads
of cool stuff to come on tonight's show
then I can't wait your side guys I don't
think she's charming anyway on that
bombshell roll the tiles
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there has been so much going on in the
eSports world over the past month that
has almost been too much almost let me
to give up with make it almost so don't
worry because as always we've got you
covered with the biggest headlines in
the eSports 60 Roundup Ready marks
always always ready go let's go our good
friends at methods secure another world
first by down in Queen Azshara
TSM stormed a victory at X Games to take
the apex of gold medal
way reveal their working play brand new
fighting game
the young guns go huge at the fortnight
World Cup for scoop a massive prizes the
latest hero to join the overwatch
universe Sigma is released for all
platforms theme empire follow up on
their win in Milan and when the Rainbow
six a rally major an OG make history at
the international life
theme liquid winner thrilling vinyl vs
cloud 9 at the LCS playoffs
[Music]
eight teams including vitality and
mousesports progressed to the legend
stage at the Berlin major oh so much
wasn't it like every month is like more
and more and more what your favorite
this obviously because like 30 million
in the prize pool there and I was he
burger won three million one point eight
I think was for second place parts
average age of the people competing a
sixteen and oldest was 24 so I think
we've kind of just well what was yours
I'm gonna say to be honest to the new
right fighting game I love the fact that
we've got a new fighting game coming
into the into the eSports space I think
there's great that we're gonna have the
FCC getting really excited about it as
well they love it I want to see some
some awesome events and I want to see
these guys you know rocking that rocking
game everyone loves new stuff anyway
right it's your time to go up there in
control center
there's so much going on but as you know
we've saw the east for 60 seconds so
last month has been insane for massive
prize pools all over the world in fact
and we reckon it must have been one of
the biggest on record says take a quick
look at the month in money okay check
this out right now month in money it was
ridiculous fortnight there thirty
million of those said Evo chanted their
700,000 fee for 500,000 prize pool total
they're going up to 33 million building
all the time 34 million call of duty
they're two million dota 2 33 million
prize pool total there 69 million which
equates to two hundred ninety two
Ferraris five Learjet 75 s 40 2715 omen
by HP gaming peace sees I mean I don't
know who run 42,000 M I just want one
mark
62 million if you could even think of
that number what would you wanna buy I
don't know but I'd feed my Lego
addiction I don't know like something
weird like that a big enough house for
that like build a house out of Lego
anything okay well whatever it's a lot
of money
thank you very much Rachel it is time
for the control center we'll be wrapping
up everything from the world of social
media and eSports in the last month and
first up we've got this tweet from Team
Liquid talking about their prayer
operation for the csgo major in Berlin
let's take a look at that tweet right
now no preparations so important for
tournaments and cater and wondering the
majors been going extremely well now if
you're wondering you know what is this
video probably just a standard bootcamp
video right no no you could be more
wrong check this out whatever happens
you did the finicky milkman the paper
boy TV
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
absolutely incredible stuff there from
the liquid guys really getting already
in the best way possible by making some
bit of a throwback content is that we're
gonna call it well next up we're gonna
look at something which really I enjoyed
I've got to say and there's our next
week coming in from fortnight stream and
World Cup commentator Jack courage
Dunlop now we all know he's got a little
bit of a thing for re and the grounders
a lot of people do but with this tweet
he might have just won the Internet
[Music]
[Music]
absolutely incredible stuff there from
Jack and one thing that I enjoyed as
well is he got the response he was
looking for as well look at this in the
ground they reply with your perfect
shout out to you jack
shoot shot sometimes it works for you
next time next up excuse me we've got an
incredible tweet coming in from slasher
that shows off the skyline of Shanghai
and of course this is a head of the
international nine and the teams taking
part are seen here in this beautiful
skyline now we all got very excited
about this we thought this looks amazing
this looks beautiful it looks absolutely
wonderful stuff Shanghai unfortunately
we saw part two of this tweet now and as
you can see here with the follow-up I
hate to do this but valve just confirmed
to me that the photos above taken from
the internationals opening trailer a
graphics for the video and not real
pictures unfortunately wasn't quite what
we wanted but had mostly internet
forward including myself but we still
love it anyway now to finish off here at
the control center it's time for an omen
update and they should get all you csgo
fans excited take a look at this it's
the omen challenge 2019
[Music]
amazing amazing stuff as you can see
they're not long to wait either as we
now know that that's taking place in
just a few weeks time in September it's
definitely gonna be a really really cool
event with amateurs mixing it up with
the pros in that 1v1 format
who are the good pros gonna be though
well keep an eye out for details by
following all of the omen by HP social
channels and maybe you'll just find out
soon now obviously that's everything
from the control center for now let's
take a look what's coming up here's
what's still to come on the show Gio
Collins helps us analyze some overwatch
in the break down we test the guest ami
skills in a headshot challenge and we
give you the inside scoop on Gamescom
2019
well an absolutely jam-packed show
tonight so do not go anywhere and my
personal favorite is the rocket League
challenger that's coming up a bit later
and that can only mean one thing
competition at time so here's what's up
for grabs
to night in this episode let's make sure
you follow the instructions on the
screen
to get your entry in for a shot at those
very very cool prize on the screen right
now right now it is time for the second
and best part of the show
in my opinion in its course time to
introduce our lovely guests this evening
hi guys we have geo cyanide and of
course mister we're clapping myself yes
not too bad not too shabby I've had a
big burger backstage backstage we're
gonna put each of you in the spotlight
but Gio you are up first I mean you do
so much you host you stream you oversee
cast is there anything you don't do oh
I'm not sure about that you put me on
the spot i peg know I hear the little
glimpses of Gio's world
[Music]
[Music]
of course you're playing in virtual
reality playing in that line environment
or with an audience on a stage is very
different due to go take a cold shower
you enjoyed that yeah when we were one
we did you didn't enjoy so you were just
saying that there are quite a few older
clips of you streaming that you don't do
as much these days no not at all I used
to stream quite a lot like five days a
week and then I really shifted my
priority to you know casting and being
on broadcast coz originally I actually
just wanted to be a streamer and then I
changed my mind and realized I actually
wanted to put all my eggs into the
basket of getting into broadcast and I
just haven't really streamed since well
speaking of commentary obviously
overwatch is kind of the thing that
you'll specialize in at the moment let's
talk about overwatch contenders because
that's something you've been heavily
involved with yourself yeah so
contenders is obviously overwatch is
Tier two kind of scene I've been working
on the Chinese region they have a load
of different regions and the way that it
kind of works is some of the regions are
sort of outsourced to third parties
which is what China is and some of them
are run directly by Blizzard and yet
it's been really interesting because you
know I I ripped that's where I wanted to
kind of end up in this situation and
China is a very hectic region yeah they
kind of play by their own rules they
don't really stick to them better or
anything like that it's been a lot of
fun to coast what got you into overwatch
in particular that any of the other
eSports well I mean I was playing
overwatch before I actually started
watching overwatch eSports and it's kind
of funny and I feel like such a clown
when I tell this story but for the
longest time for the longest time I
remember being like I really wish
overwatch for a nice book because I
wanted to get into eSports for the
longest time but all my friends were
into other games that I wasn't really
playing and interested in so I thought
that that sorting sports woods and then
when overwatch week started and I was
like well cool I'm gonna watch this I
realized that it already been going for
Nick hopefully you for that point and
felt like such an idiot so I was already
into the game and we obviously took my
overwatch there's new character I guess
a new hero
we've got Sigma he's the kind of
gravity-defying character with well
you're gonna describe it but what what
changing in the Metra in the game and
just think kind of everyone's gonna take
to him I mean yeah he's an interesting
character I think what you're referring
to you look at this man just doesn't own
shoes he just chooses not to win
everybody her first name as toes rose
like what we gonna kind of see from so
he's very interesting character he's
kind of coming in as people didn't
really know if he was gonna be an off
tank or a main tank and I think right
now people have realized he's gonna take
that off tank role and people mean
coupling up with ERISA quite a lot and
he's gonna be able to provide that that
shield that you can kind of place
anywhere on the map so you'll have a
constant recyclable shield which is
really quite oppressive so we're like me
to be seeing some very like sort of a
long range play getting DPS heroes like
Mei Hanzo or a Symetra who have that
she'll break they can pierce through his
abilities quite well but yeah he's
really gonna be quite an impressive hero
what's the reaction been like to him so
far um people were really excited and he
when he was first announced to be honest
and a lot of people said that Blizzard's
announcement of of him because they
always released like a video with sort
of some background story a lot of people
said it was the best one that they've
done so far and so people have been very
excited and obviously everyone gets
excited whenever a new here is announced
to see what it is they're gonna offer
for the game but I think some people a
little bit tend to do a little bit
nervous about how how hard he might be
to be I think that everyone's always a
little bit nervous or something useful
let's talk about competition let's talk
about the upcoming iw playoffs because
I've watched obviously huge competition
coming up what your thoughts on that
who's going to take the title inside
scoop from gee it's so hard to tell
right now I mean I think one of the
really interesting things about it at
the moment is the fact that London spear
fire who won the entire thing last
season they're currently in planes so
they haven't they haven't directly may
playoffs they have to get into the top
two in the plane's bracket in order to
actually get there so it's kind of a
testament to how much overwatch has
changed over over the course of the last
year but it's very interesting because
this to-to-to lot came in for Stage four
a lot of the teams that weren't
necessarily doing as well earlier on in
the season and now are actually sitting
in these top spots so it's been really
unpredictable
to me I would say my favorites of San
Francisco shop giving us the prediction
as well Vancouver tightens there they're
sort of the team that consistently have
been at the top but I think personally
San Francisco a lot more flexible and
they can offer a lot more and they have
beaten Vancouver at certain points in
the competition
and so they've always kind of been like
this but I think in this case San
Francisco sort of happier not all the
names like London's going with something
like London tea drinkers clamouring are
gonna want something like yes you guys
watch you kind of know any of these
teams expected to do well I mean I've
always supported London Spitfire just
because London I don't think it's it's
it's impossible to ignore
I think overwatch League you know you
see it everywhere Twitter on Twitch all
over the place you know it's just
everyone's talking about it as well when
the league's on it's it's it doesn't
matter if you're interested in overwatch
or not it will come to you so well
you've heard the predictions for the
overwatch playoffs so I'm gonna put
money on that you know what to do I do
said it but they're still coming over
happening anyway somebody's coming up
here's what you're not gonna wear miss
still to come on tonight's show omen
squad member cyanide joins us on the
sofa things get heated in the rocket
League challenge and we learn about the
rise and fall of the
spoke quite
time for my favorite part of the show
the headshot challenge this week psy and
I took on Dan and as always we added a
little twist just to spice things up
this is the csgo headshot challenge
cyanide today is taking on damnit Gaskin
I believe you actually took part in
series one didn't you I did yeah it was
alright I was very solidly mid-tier I
was like 20 I think maybe sighs go like
that yeah but we're gonna make it a
little bit more tricky this time out
okay
so I've had we're gonna ask you some
would you roll over questions which I'm
a rather unique okay man they have a lot
of thought into these okay six seconds
on the clock time starts when you make
your first headshot got it okay yeah
okay whenever you're ready he's underway
okay would you rather lose the ability
to read or the ability to speak the
ability to speak okay he took cut you
can't speak any more than right be
covered in fur or carpeting scale
covered for we're not gonna speak but
it's fine
live the rest of your life on a boat or
in a caravan drinking come on think
about your son caravan I get seasick I
agree with you there be forced to dance
whenever you heard music or have to sing
every single song see yeah I can't sing
okay you better sing oh no no okay oh
yeah a street fighter or Tekken are you
happy whoa no thank you very much it's
time for Dan Katz guitar go Dan Gaskin
is in the hot seat
okay Lucy busy to read or the ability to
speak probably read because I'd rather
talk to people with you be covered in
fur or covered in scales scales cuz I
hate hair you bit of a fish I just hate
hair give up all drinks but water or
give up what food uh Waldron's but water
okay have a limited food or unlimited
first-class travel
unlimited five seconds are you a street
fight or Tekken
Street Fighter okay that's it time is
mouse down how'd that you go on I did
really well okay well don't reveal it
because I'm about to do that the cyanide
right now so we don't know what the
scores just yet but apparently Dan was a
bit fuzzy Marquess already saying I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that he
knows stuff about sittest I didn't know
existed
are you wanna do tricks I wanna ask you
one of the questions because she didn't
get to play would you rather have fur or
scales there's a lot of money to be made
up being a fairy course no we're gonna
reveal the scores at right now no no he
was cheating he I tell you what though
this guy right before before we actually
got on stage he was sad they're
practicing for a solid like our you take
that nap out of the equation you put
some practice you can't complain me
getting a better why it's great to sleep
under a table if you're rested you
perform well I beat on set I beat Bravo
I'd be Paul I'd be Sims I've got a first
you know sorry I gotta go yeah I'd be ok
anyway well done again cyanide no
nineteen isn't that bad anyway right if
you're a fan of overwatch you're not
going to want to miss this next section
do mark broke down the major moment for
a recent owlplz
alright ladies and gentlemen it's time
for my favorite part of every single
show it is the breakdown we have Gio
joining us up now overwatch commentator
of course and we're gonna be talking
overwatch and speaking of overwatch bit
of a mesh shift recently in the game
yeah there has been they've now
implemented what is called the 2-2 to
lock which is where you have to play to
DPS two tanks to supports where it's
obviously previously we had the world
famous of goats meta where you'd play
three tanks and three supports and then
a little bit of a triple DPS matter as
well so this is really gonna change the
dynamics of the game now speaking of
change you're speaking of dynamics we
have a clip that you want to talk
through yeah which is from last
weekend's overwatch League where we have
seen this new meta introduced give us a
little bit of background before we get
into it very quickly and then we'll run
through the clip so basically the whole
idea of this clip is it's one of those
classic stall situations you're the
defending team you're trying to stop an
attacking team from taking the point and
oftentimes in overwatch this doesn't
really work because you send out
different players at different times and
eventually they get overwhelmed but this
is a really good example of a defending
team actually succeeding in their store
well let's have a look at this clip then
and talk us through so here we have the
gladiators they're trying to take this
point and the LA valiant they're trying
to come in now here we actually see this
amplification matrix come out from the
Battiste
now the amplification matrix will double
any of the damage that is going through
it so the idea is that as you're a
valiant start to filter in they can deal
in so much damage on to them that it's
going to be too hard but what la valiant
decide to do is they send in their
offtank player space right here on the
diva now he actually puts up his defense
matrix in front of the a matrix so he'll
be swallowing up any of that projectile
damage that comes in through that damage
boost and of course we have a Hanzo and
a Battiste right in front of it both of
whom do give projectile damage so
they're gonna be mitigated there now
while he's hogging all the attention we
see care safe on the hands they actually
jump in start cleaning up those kills we
see him in the kill feed getting all the
damage they need to actually be able to
pull over time all the way down and
succeed in defending the point so they
succeeded they kept their wits about
them communications such a vital part of
that yeah it's really important because
you know you always have this in-game
leader in the game and generally that
works very well when the team is all
together but in those really
high-pressure situations where anything
can change in the
wink of an eye that's where it's not as
easy to have that in-game leader so you
do have to be very communicative
now speaking of people at home who can
add that to the game what would you be
saying to add something to their game to
sort of improve their overwatch
basically if you want to take anything
from this you need to know that a yes
you have to communicate and be it's a
really good idea to not all be
bloodthirsty going for various different
targets that won't work out very well
take from this what they did when they
send in one person to try and mitigate
that damage and off the back of that
someone else to try and deal in their
own damage and that's how you get the
cleanup because the second that you're
all looking at different targets and all
panicking that's where you'll get
overwhelmed by the attacking team so
stay cool stay calm and stay composed
you can always pull off that comeback
especially when things aren't quite
looking like they're gonna be going your
way geo absolutely fantastic we've
talked about overwatch League but we've
got plenty more to come on the show so
let's take a look at what's coming up
still to come
dank Gaskin joins us to talk all things
eSports his team mark versus team
Rachael in the rocket League challenge
and we take a look at what to be excited
for in the month ahead as you can see
ladies and gents so much more to come
this evening but Gio I've got a question
for you which is have you ever been
scams come I have not have you I have
been to games come what a fantastic
thing to say I went there last week to
check everything out let's take a look
what's up guys and girls and welcome to
the beautiful city of Cologne Germany
we'll be taking you around one of the
biggest and most anticipated gaming
exhibitions in the world if you hadn't
guessed by now
this is Gamescom 2019 so we're here at
the entrance now and these doors behind
me are gonna have thousands and
thousands of gamers stream in and all
week long trying to catch a taste of
some of the issues hottest releases now
to me that sounds like a pretty good
idea so I'm gonna head in I'm gonna go
into it
so Ivan Point 2077 is one of the most
anticipated games of the year and you
can see exactly why look at the length
is cute everyone wants to get their
hands on it why are you so excited for
cyberpunk 2077 really like all the other
things that CD Projekt RED have done so
far this game have been announced seven
years ago or something like that so I'm
excited to get my hands on everything I
can get gameplay demo the art everything
worse the three-hour wait probably I
hope so HB stand there's some amazing
pcs downstairs some amazing hardware the
eSports area but I had to come up here
because I've always wanted to become a
human cool I feel like you're having a
lot higher than it should be
catch most-asked like going to the
chiropractor my back's like snap back
into place
one of the great things about Gamescom
is that you find the little diamonds you
wouldn't have expected to play before
and one game that I've just been playing
his role of champions
that game was so much fun I'm definitely
picking it up and comes out PC he was
sleeping camera well let's meet well
market I do what are you excited about
today yeah obviously in the keep it yeah
I'm excited to play obviously like
rip and tear some demons and whatnot
should be good I've managed to bump into
my good friend Daniel gasket a sports
commentator extraordinaire what do you
think the significance of eSports at
Gamescom isn't I think we've already
seen it grow from the years that I've
just been in attendance but I think it
will get bigger and bigger and it's it's
good to be here because it gives it to a
wider audience because some of the
public they don't really know about you
sports they just like video games as a
whole but we get to show them the
competitive side I think that's
important because then I'm gonna get
more eSports fans and I think yeah let's
get more eSports at Gamescom so when
we're thinking about eSports are we're
thinking about the highest tier of
competition we're thinking Simon we
think intensity we think farming
simulator
let's go how are you doing
congratulations on well first thanks so
much I'm doing great
just enjoying the first day at Gamescom
I'm actually only here for a couple of
days but it's pretty much just backpack
knees and then I'm heading out to
undisclosed location for a pretty
exciting event for classic quiet you get
to give it to the info the Intel I mean
I'm afraid it's gonna get announced real
soon you guys may already see it by the
time this comes out but yeah we're gonna
be doing a lot of stuff very classic
World of Warcraft so really excited
about her amazing stuff thank you dude
all the best
so that's it our time here at Gamescom
has sadly come to an end and what a
spectacle it was my one takeaway from
this experience is if you're a hardcore
gamer or you're just a casual fan of
video games there really is something
for everyone
Gamescom it's been an absolute pleasure
we'll see you next year well obviously
glamour there mark was there cyanide you
there as well yeah it was a whole lot of
fun a whole lot of fun yeah and you're
obviously on the omens and because
you're part of the omens squad yes
you're also a streamer yes you're pretty
busy you are telling me as well
occasionally yeah there's a look at your
world wait what
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
reporting the fact I forgot a parachute
and that's a [ __ ] I don't know what to
feel about that from the twitch app
dodge games are STIs nice yes
no not too bad how much grief do you
think you'll get from redeye after that
performance so dodge red I am myself for
a group of friends we have a group chat
so yeah I'm gonna hope that it kind of
slides by him and he doesn't notice he's
pretty old so he might not notice did
you
[Laughter]
against him in last season's report
against Paul maybe yeah he was in it he
was in it yeah yeah I remember the
scores I did way better than he pours
you can remember that what you want
anyway that's kind of jacked a little
bit more about you and obviously you are
at Gamescom over there with the widow
Monon they're kind of sad where else
were you up to that so I did a bunch of
stage activities for omen and then we
filmed a bunch of content with them and
you know stuff for them to use on their
channel stuff for me to use on mine they
actually said they wanted me to film a
vlog going down to the gamescom so they
said hey why don't you drive down to
Germany and I was like that is a
fantastic idea I will happily drive down
to Germany on the Autobahn looks really
confused
well what stage activities do I look
like I'm capable of a handstand no saw
like we went up on stage and we
basically played with people from the
crowd like we picked like you know you
generally get before the stage times
like a hundred or so people
from there and it's a lot of fun because
you get to throw stuff at people you
thought much not at them yeah it was
pretty cool I like seeing a lot of
people go up on it though there's a lot
of fun night I saw people like grabbing
cuz the idea was you grab as many of the
foam boxes as you can and I saw people
like grabbing them and putting it on
their back and grabbing some with their
mouths and speaking of cool events
another cool event that you were
involved with yourself is obviously the
pop G Nations Cup yeah you're out in
South Korea I believe yeah that was wow
that was a really cool experience
because I didn't expect it you know they
they kind of messaged me like a month
before and I was like well I had no idea
and then I got there and it was you know
one of the best produced eSports events
that I've ever actually been to like you
can see on the screen are absolutely
incredible this yeah this was this was
broadcast to twitch and they're kind of
a are stuff that they're doing here
it was very cool except dad seems to
think that those those are actually say
so still you know the awesome thing
about it was that none of the teams that
ever played with each other before so I
was incredibly hectic nobody and nobody
had a clue what anyone else was doing so
it just led to like a bunch of crazy
plays and the rise of my favorite player
of all time duck man he's like 1v3 other
teams just like it's nobody's business
you're a streamer but you have a quite a
strong friendship with the pro gamer
there MBK obviously place of vitality
yeah you guys kind of play against each
other a bit how many how did that
friendship come about in the first place
well it started off not as a joke but it
started off on a joke we kind of messing
around he watched a few of the [ __ ]
videos that we let Soviet does on
YouTube and stuff like that and you
touch second you want to play a couple
of games let's have a bit of fun you
know you know so played a few and then
we started talking about cause when it
that's when it was like okay this guy
this is my guy like you know so we say
that however you know we must bring
something up which is also cool
obviously when he gave you it
we'll call it a shout out a pretty
strong performance so yeah he he what
was it he won the tournament I think he
I was did he win a game I can't remember
181 the tournament and then so he won
the tournament I'd have bet with him
before the tournament said if you win
right I'm believing in you so if you win
you've got to shout me out and Nathan
being Nathan he he won and then he went
up on stage and decided to do the
absolute opposite of shout me out which
was be very sneaky yes so that was that
I guess this is my chance cuz he's
coming up to a big yes you gonna what
you gonna say to him your chance right
now I'll be camera please
I'm gonna be that cuz we had we had a
very serious discussion a few weeks ago
about how he's doing super well and
stuff like that so I want to back him
and then when he's got a bit of success
and stuff like that with vitality that's
when I'm gonna be snarky
after he's won a bunch of stuff and he's
like you know got accolades and stuff
you bring him back down that's my plan
so good luck Nathan we go in exactly
with vitality and then the next one I'm
after you later it's a very delicious
complaint
thank you so much obviously you will be
you'll be involved with the conversation
a little bit more but now is the time to
talk about one of the games that started
it all we look back at one of the
forefathers of eSport this is the rise
and fall of quake quake is a truly
three-dimensional simulation of combat
with some of the grooviest weapons you
can use for hands-on I know I've went
through every 3d game this out there
very much a 3d game buff and
quake just rules them all
[Music]
now how do you like the idea of being
paid to play sport on your computer UK's
first cyberathlete this Cambridge
Dragoon sujay Roy he owns a living
increasing the body count in the
computer game crate 3 I've been a game
of my whole life but I started taking it
seriously back in 1996 when quake came
out that was the first time you could
play online against anyone all over the
world it was just mind-blowing to me
basically because I was already
interested in like the burgeoning
internet culture when you found out you
could play games or Theban if that was
obviously a sick concept you felt like
you were in some futuristic realm in
that regard and so it was an addiction
in that area like you it was a new
experience cuz you were playing against
a real person when it's software
released quake in 1996 it gave players
something they'd not experienced before
a true online first-person shooter and
the first taste of competitive gaming
back then obviously there was wasn't
even a conception of something called
eSports there was just sometimes people
might put on tournament events were well
let's just say there were a collection
of people we didn't really matter where
we were we were kind of organizing
ourselves it was community run generally
the gaming was just as competitive and
players I think had the same attitude of
wanting to win regardless 1997 saw its
software hosted tournament in Atlanta
whereby players competed to win John
Carmack's Ferrari a player by the name
of Thresh took home the grand prize just
the concept you could win that in a gear
my quake is mental over the next few
years the series saw a meteoric rise in
popularity players like Sue joy were
gaining recognition worldwide the
concept of professional gaming was
becoming less obscure and it was all
thanks to quake quake was the only
eSport at the time quake was the only
game that people talked about but still
it wasn't growing as we thought the
different versions of the games kept
splitting the community are in two
segments that didn't play with each
other and that was a disaster just as it
was getting popular really felt like it
wasn't gonna be sustained and
you wait for a new quake tidal had built
anticipation within the community but
the announcement of quake champions
didn't quite rise to the occasion when
quake champions first came out people
loved playing quake again the problem
was it could immediately tell by the
change they made these are changes to
appeal to overwatch crowd to appeal to
people play league of legends by
changing the whole dynamic it just
didn't work unfortunately so there were
a few mistakes made quite champion
suffered because of that because there
was a huge splash but it didn't really
hit critical mass at QuakeCon London
2019 quake had a modest presence but
what does the future hold for the
franchise that gave us our first taste
of 3d environments clans and online
multiplayer competition the announcement
of a remastered quake 2 which boasts
cutting-edge ray tracing technology has
stirred hope within the community
the reimagining of this old-school
shooter again shows its software's
devotion to innovation and could be the
right step in putting quake back on top
[Applause]
oh joy a while ago and he was like yeah
yeah back when I played quake it's like
oh wow when was that he was like 96 and
I was like I was that was a year I was
bald man at that point driving so joy
you guys played it we were fan of the
game I played Quaker RTX quake I have
played yes it was a lot of fun it was
very raw shooter
you know like super fast pace oh yeah
absolutely pop yeah I've actually never
played it I feel like it would be a very
me game especially as you know the hero
that I play the most nerve which is the
one that all of the XF era is the one
that all the ex crate players went to
because she has a rocket boost or a
rocket jump and she shoots rocket so
very quake style so I feel like I should
have done myself a disservice by not
having played it quite as a new fan in
do right there it's time to introduce
our third and final guests okay
this guy he kind of costs more eSports
than I don't even know what to do with
this guy can't clearly have much time
for much else Dan Gaskin
this is a look into what you get up to
have you ever looked into the sky and
you start I wish I was a star I'm a
change bad now so I am been on the
Japanese toilet
there's lots of room for activities he
follows in the milliseconds later we see
a subscription that was interesting it's
not very good does it go any better my
dabbing anyway I mean that's kind of
like some old-school stuff on there is
that wasn't it some of it was quite
relevant quite recent the dabbing was it
kind of just happened there's a reflex
but obviously you saw you there on the
hearthstone casting desk I mean I use
you know involved in that as much
anymore but kind of do like warehouse
stones going now I mean I did half stone
for two years mainly the global games
then the global games stopped so that's
kind of why I'm not really involved as
much anymore some of my best friends are
still involved in hearthstone so I get
to kind of find out what's going on and
the way it's going the latest expansions
been great the way that the team is
reacting to all the card changes and
making sure the matter is nice and
stable they try but the matter always
manages to get unstable and there's
always Opie cards that's what happens in
card games but yeah I like the direction
they're going I know the players are a
little bit unsure about some of the like
specific things and they want some
tweaks but we'll see what happens and I
mean I wouldn't allow I would happily do
it again because I'm a big fan of the
game no it's not just a small Passport
just take a sip of water and see you're
super busy at the moment and you do a
variety of different eSports you're
involved with whoever is commentating
whether it's hosting etc talk to me
about some of the challenges have been a
multi game commentator though because
you know doing one for some people is
tough enough how do you sort of manage
the workload it's very tough a to stay
involved in every single community I
mean naturally when my transition from
hearthstone doing a lot of FIFA a lot
hearthstone followers I guess I have
those on social media they would stop
following me because they're not
interested in FIFA which is fair enough
it's also very hard to stay up to date
with matters etc you've got to play the
game a lot what updates have there been
the best way to do that is to play a lot
of video games which I'm actually quite
good at because I'm a massive nerd
that's good and half stone was an easier
one because you have it on your mobile I
can confirm this Israel like when we
were at tournaments cuz I'm fortunate
unfortunate wherever you want to be sat
in a meeting in a green room production
me and Dan will have his laptop open and
he will be playing some game whether
it's you know hearthstone whether it's
you know f1 whatever it is you're always
playing something he's not listening to
production because you're not going to
review all these things wait wait a
second was he listening but obviously we
just mention a few of the eSports you're
involved and just kind of list off which
ones you currently work on right now
I guess so halo FIFA will be to my big
ones I'm keen on working on background
like apex like if you're hearthstone I
did asphalt legends I kind of I can do
most things if I have the time to
prepare for it I can't I can't even keep
up with a controlled scheme of like
three games and you got 19 kills it it's
just it's crazy to me like it's and I'll
make you feel better I did play csgo
competitively for about a year this is
your excluded who's top again
so you put me up against the csgo former
pro no no I probably just anyway
obviously done we're talking about the
casting side of things you also do some
hosting as well and we know you're
hosting a little bit at Gamescom and you
tweet it saying you're a little bit
nervous because you haven't staged
hosted in a while yes it had been I
think around a year since I last stage
hosted and it was kind of last minute as
well so that always adds to the nerves I
thought I was gonna maybe be desk
hosting instead but I found out was
stage hosting so I looked for
Comfort on the internet which apparently
what I do and that's we like some
machine golden-boy shocks because I know
that they have made similar tweets when
they've been doing things that are not
maybe comfortable with and that made me
sleep easier that night knowing that I'm
not the only one but it went really well
how different though is casting from
hosting and I kind of do you do that as
well you kind of do both it's a
conversation that me and Jo have had
backstage you are kind of left to your
own devices and you're left on your own
a lot of course you've got the producer
in your ear and whatnot but if that
thing goes off of that battery dies then
it's all up to you you're in charge of
the show you're driving the conversation
and you don't have anyone to fall back
on always terrified of not hearing
exactly what the producers yeah because
there's no way you can say wait can you
repeat that kind of kind of in the air
but I'm gonna move on now anyway guys
thank you so much dad right this is
again where my favorite part is it so
much fun this is the rocket League
challenging at the moment the scores are
still in my favor I am to one up against
this man mark here but we had two new
partners this week or actually three
because he cheated a little bit anyway
to mate
here's how things is that what you were
ladies and gentlemen it is time once
again for the rocket League challenge
and this week we have obviously a change
up for the teams of our guests we have
Rachel aka the loser of last week's
challenge alongside cyanide cyanide
you've got to not be feeling too
confident about this right hang on no
witty one up okay over here overall
we're about to tie things up and I'm so
confident this week I've got Dan Gaskin
to start things off and behind I've got
Gio who I'm gonna be tagging in at some
point because to be honest we all feel
like we should get win right I
understand if you want to join Team Marc
as well
this is over you go get back and I'm
just spinning around
[Music]
lay down it's actually quite fun being
the spectator I had spikes yes skill
here everyone missed
[Applause]
okay 13 seconds left on a forward to
defend just go for it it's all undone
I'm Nick evil favorite seconds to go I
hit it button or hit wait it's not it's
not winner booty Ranger Phil Casio that
seam down I know how Arsenal feel now
three one I mean thank keep it
partnering up team Rachael cyanide air
we work that's for both of you as well
we have four one down I've redeemed
myself from pcs go ahead shot you have
indeed there were there was three of
them now an important factor yeah for
one down whilst I was playing you know
we were just pray anyway guys three one
up what you say I'm not gonna lie wasn't
my strongest performance but no neither
was the week before last so you know
whatever I tell you what let's move on
let's just forget about rocking leave
for a minute three one let's have a look
at Philadelphia plays host to the second
ever overwatch League grand finals the
London Spitfire look to defend their
title from some fierce competition this
year after seven weeks the best of
British League of Legends Excel and
fnatic come head to head live from
Twickenham Stadium on September first
[Music]
Berlin host the next csgo major will
favorites Team Liquid claim the title or
will we see another team rise to the
challenge as Blizzcon draws near and the
end of the Starcraft 2 season looms WCS
full marks the last major of the year
starting September SiC Dreamhack returns
to Canada for another installment of the
world's biggest LAN oven catch action
from rocket League Rainbow six and more
over the weekend
Europe has seen a strong performance in
league of legends this year and the LEC
finals are looking to be unmissable
catch all the action
September 7th inning
yeah month ahead is so busy but guys
have you got much going on in the next
month Dan start with you first I can't
confirm much but I'll be probably in
Poland then down then San Francisco then
New York all in one trip that was busy
because Wow cyanide
I'm spending the next month in bed yeah
game song tired I'm chilling dear well
the horse season is over now so most of
that's done so I've got a couple of
small things but nothing big plans so
yeah I'm gonna give the girl a job she
wants more work I mean I've had a pretty
sad end to this show I must say with the
rocket League defeat and the way that
everything went down but it's my time to
spread some happiness across the world
and nothing to announce our competition
went up
[Music]
it's exciting so I'll give that little
bit dramatic thanks dad right okay we
have the golden envelope read it and the
winner is Jacob
[Applause]
anyway guys that's all we have time for
this evening guys thank you so much for
coming on you can take those little uh
party horns you could take it cyanide
you can have that or me don't want that
but anyway guys thank you so much for
watching it's been great but please do
join us on the 18th of September for the
next episode of The Omen eSports
reports until then thanks Russ and good
night good night
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you